Yesterday, we learned that Republican Senator
Rand Paul is the first senator to contract
Corona virus.
Rand Paul's staff tweeting
out yesterday, quote, Senator Rand.
Paul has tested positive for covered 19.
He's feeling fine and is in quarantine.
He's asymptomatic and was tested out of abundance
of caution due to his extensive travel and
events.
He was not aware of any direct contact with
any infected person.
Now, despite not being aware that he had contact
with an infected person as an infected person
himself, there are reports that he went to
the Senate gym to work out after being tested.
But before receiving the results, his staff
was asked about it and they said he didn't
go anywhere after getting his positive test
result, which, of course, wasn't the question.
The question was, did he go to the gym after
being tested on an abundance of caution.
But before the results and it appears that
he did.
But what we do know is he had lunch with a
whole bunch of Republican senators, including
Mitt Romney.
And so Mitt Romney yesterday said the following.
And Paul has been diagnosed with Kogut, 19.
Wish him the very best.
He's compromised given health conditions he's
had in the past.
And so we'll be praying for him and thinking
thinking about it.
And of course, all the senators are going
to seek medical advice as to what action we
should take to make sure that we don't in
any way spread this virus herself together.
Yes.
We're not we're in a lunch together with Rand.
And I hope he's doing very well.
But we have to determine whether any of us
should self-quarantine as a result of being
in the same room.
And indeed, shortly thereafter, we learned
that Mitt Romney himself is self-quarantine.
Now, Donald Trump during yesterday's lie riddled
Gong Show propaganda press briefing, was told
that Romney was in quarantine.
And Trump sarcastically says, oh, gee, that's
too bad.
With a doofy look on his face, of course,
is dripping with sarcasm.
Trump known not to like Mitt Romney for a
while.
And in particular, since Mitt Romney voted
to convict Donald Trump on impeachment on
one of the two counts.
Check this out.
And Trump actually asked whether it was sarcasm
to which Trump sarcastically responds, Oh,
no, no, no sarcasm here.
Come on, top of Senator Paul.
Now, for senators are in isolation and the
rules say that and we're going to vote to
get rid of it too early.
Senator Crossin says Senator Rick Scott, also
two of them were in contact with Rick is up
with the critical stimulus package vote, except
Romney's in isolation.
Yes.
Gee, that's too bad.
I detect sarcasm there.
No, none whatsoever.
Trump barely able to contain his glee that
a potent political adversary of his might
be infected with life threatening illness.
Remember Mitt Romney, 73 years old, certainly
at risk of a serious case of coronavirus if
he were to catch it.
And Trump says, gee, that's too bad.
Sarcastically.
Note that Trump made this comment about Romney
after he bragged during the same press conference
that he had done this amazing job uniting
Democrats and Republicans and bringing the
country together.
He's just a bad person, guys.
There's not we don't need a deeper analysis.
There's nothing else to it.
People are dying.
People's friends, family members, colleagues
are sick in the hospital.
And Trump's joking around about a political
adversary having to self-quarantine